my mission statement would be the
following I imagine the people
contrivances kind to a pine as well as
to listen and I'd never leave well
anyone can decently claim that they have
an unanswered question and a second I
think one has to be a spellbinding
person to speak for more than say half
an hour even if one spellbinding one
doesn't really need the half hour either
but I did want to say a few things about
the jefferson factor and then to become
your prisoner as you've been my hostage
so so kindly up till now and i want to
talk about him under three or four
headings really enlightenment warned
revolution nation-building and slavery
philadelphia in the second half of the
18th century may not exactly have been
5th century Athens but it was an
extraordinary place and time and
coincidence of what I think of as in
Enlightenment scholarship people who
knew and cared about the sciences about
biology about medicine about law about
engineering all seemed to be there at
the same time in an extraordinary way
some of it was connected to the Scottish
enlightenment some of it to the French
but it had a distinctively American
flavor to it and it drew other people to
itself as well not just of course the
famous dr. Franklin and dr. Benjamin
Rush and others but when dr. Joseph
Priestley for example who went we can
more or less say discovered oxygen half
his laboratory smashed in Birmingham
England for his profane experiments in
his dissenting opinions by a mob calling
itself Church and King for royalty and
for the altar
when his scientific career was put an
end to in Birmingham he took ship for
Philadelphia it was a magnet place one
of the ways in which I sometimes try and
make audiences cry and sometimes succeed
will see is to remind you what choice
the American electorate had in 1796 for
candidates for president it could choose
between the chairman of the American
Society of Arts and Letters and the
founding president of the American
Academy of Sciences has been a bit of a
decline in the standards of candidacy
since then and not only did have this
choice but none of the rules of
obtaining at that period it could and in
fact did vote for both of them because
the runner-up in those days was vice
president so we're talking about a
serious moment of what I still naively
like to think of as the Enlightenment I
would define it like this the the belief
in free inquiry the belief in scientific
experiment the ability to conduct and
test such things and the belief that
this was itself an emancipation not just
from disease or ignorance or stupidity
though there were such conflicts for
example Thomas Jefferson not only
organized a program of inoculation
against smallpox which he extended by
the way to all of his slaves at
Monticello but he also helped dr. Jenner
organize a system whereby the vaccine
could be transported without losing its
efficacy once the method of cooling it
and keeping it cool had been found and
this was at the time when Timothy Dwight
the best-known divine of the day still
celebrated at Yale was saying that
inoculation against smallpox was a
interference with God's design which of
course if you believe in intelligent
design would be true or in yaghan from
design at all it was indeed an
interference with God's design if if
such there be these were the sort of
stakes that were being played for I
suppose I mentioned the Dwight Jefferson
difference for
for a secondary but important reason
those who believed in scientific inquiry
and and in the life of the mind and in
the proper conduct of experiments where
they be astronomical or biological did
believe that it was time that human
beings took responsibility for
themselves and ceased to rely upon
divine suasion of any sort and I think
that that essentially secular insight
was what made possible the American
Revolution there was going to be an
American Revolution anyway here I moved
to the Warren Revolution point
effectively once General Wolfe has
defeated the French army in Quebec on
the plains of Abraham has defeated
General Montcalm the American Revolution
is is more or less inevitable because
it's the product of a struggle for power
between three empires in the North
American continent the French the
Spanish and the British and once the
French had been evicted from Canada and
the English of signed the and the French
of signed the Treaty of a Miao which
gave England the right having defeated
France in North America in India on the
high seas and in Europe to claim one
French colony many said in London let's
take Guadeloupe it will complete our
control of the Caribbean Basin will
ensure our control over sugar and slaves
others said no surely Canada would be
better more mercantile future a greater
future for our settlers and our
manufactured goods and the Guadeloupe
faction the paid pamphleteers of the
Duke of Bridgewater as it turns out
journalists were paid off even in those
days said we'll watch out what beware of
what you want because if you take Canada
then the North American settlers the
colonists will no longer require our
protection against France and what
stirrings of Independence there seem to
be already among them they seem to be in
Philadelphia and elsewhere developing
ideas of their own and actually the Duke
of Bridgewater faction was very
prescient as in a very few years the
supporters of King George in those
colonies were heading for Canada as Tory
refugees but at the importance of
Jefferson to this stage is as follows he
was um
in several ways almost a Leninist to his
absolute concentration on three things
handling of interim purest
contradictions playing off France
written in Spain at all times trying to
enlarge the scope and power of the
United States insisting that the United
States have a declaration of
independence that involved and program
promulgated as far as it could
enlightenment opinions and always
seeking to extend this power to the
Mississippi and the interior if it
weren't for his extraordinary focus on
this the United States might have been
to North America what Chile is to South
America a long literal ribbon of a
country caught between the ocean and the
mountains no shame to be Chile to be
sure but it wouldn't have become the
United States as we think of a nerve it
today and worn revolution were his
speciality and he was extremely as I say
very cold and ruthless in pursuing the
American interest at all costs in this
respect always backing the French
Revolution always saying even that the
cost of his political career at one
point as Secretary of State that the
fact that there was now another Republic
on the face of the earth that America
was no longer alone that the ideas of
the American Revolution had been written
partly by himself and by Thomas Paine
into the first French Universal
Declaration of Human Rights that this
was above all important that it meant
that there was going to be a limit
eventually to the to the power of the
British Empire to circumscribe American
independence but I can't claim that he
was always on the side of revolution
because the most important revolution
that occurred after the French on this
side of the Atlantic in this hemisphere
in the Caribbean was the Haitian
Revolution to which all of you here our
debt but I don't think all of you
understand there's a wonderful book by
CLR James called black jacobins it's
about the first slave successful slave
rebellion in history and the
proclamation of the first ever black
emancipated Republic under the
leadership of a brilliant general
named Toussaint L'Ouverture which took
the slogans of the French Revolution and
turned them on the French colonial
masters and slave owners of Haiti and
was drowned in blood but not before it
had destroyed a French army and a French
fleet and not before it had forced
Bonaparte to consider that he was in
urgent need of money to finance is
equally ludicrous and sane war against
Russia and that therefore he might as
well abandon Haiti and offer the
churches of Louisiana for sale to the
United States
Jefferson is an irony of history if you
like Jefferson hated and feared the
Haitian Revolution he feared that a
slave rebellion might spread to Georgia
and the Carolinas that it might be about
example but thanks to the extraordinary
courage and determination of the slaves
of Haiti the French Empire is broke
enough to say we will I think Henry
Adams puts it the best gives you the
opportunity to double the size of your
country in one day for 10 cents an acre
unfortunately the money for this had to
be raised privately Jefferson didn't
feel that necessary to consult Congress
but there was as you'll find in any
study of his contradictions nothing he
wouldn't do and no principle of his that
he would not negate if it would lead to
an enhancement of the size or the scope
or the strength of the United States of
America and that explains some but not
all of the ways in which he contradicts
himself moving staying with war leaving
revolution for a moment the other great
thing oh I should just say one more
thing about the Louisiana Purchase which
was his great stroke of genius it was
something that had been meditated by him
for a long time he'd always wanted to
control of the Mississippi and
especially of New Orleans but he'd
prepared for it were in advance he
wasn't just improvising or opportunist
on the day which happens to be the 4th
of July that the Gazette in Washington
announced the Louisiana Purchase on that
exact same day Lewis and Clark received
their instructions to depart on their
expedition to the west which had been
long in preparation
again an Enlightenment project Jefferson
sent them to Philadelphia to be educated
in mapmaking in astronomy in biology in
medicine
indeed in in conducting inoculations
against smallpox mother thinks he sent
them to see Benjamin Rush and many other
very celebrated physicians and
scientists and he was able to tell them
as they set out on this occasion you can
tell the chiefs of the native peoples
and tribal nations who you encounter you
can tell them when you meet with them
and treat with them and I urge you to
treat them with respect and courtesy you
can tell them that they already live in
the United States they may not know it
yet but they do they are no longer
sovereign subject to the sovereignty of
the Emperor of France so the combination
of these two things makes it a certainty
that one day the United States will
become what it now is a continental
power that's the sort of wars I promised
you Jefferson is the first president to
commit the United States to war overseas
and to send the US Army Navy and Marine
Corps across the Atlantic and to make
them plant the Stars and Stripes on
foreign sort of the occasion on which
chooses to do this is almost as soon as
he's elected president for many years
he's decided that the must and will be
war with the Muslim slave states and
piratical states of the Ottoman Empire
in northwest Africa what we what we now
know as Algiers Algeria Libya Tunisia
and Morocco then called the Barbary
States partly because of the presence of
a large Berber population partly cuz
Barbary is a good propaganda word
because it sounds like barbaric but
actually the word for the policy of
these states at that time was was
barbarism their empire depended on
piracy hostage taking and slave owning
it's been estimated by the best
historians of the most brilliant
recently Linda Colley has written that
upwards of one and a half million
Europeans were taken and held as slaves
by these countries who commanded the
Straits of Gibraltar and the opening to
the Mediterranean
between about 1750 and 1850 raid east
west as well as north south but their
principal slave population was as it
were European they are very
sophisticated ships they could send them
as far north as Scotland in Ireland the
whole population of the town of
Baltimore in Ireland was carried off in
one day into slavery by these people and
they exactly attribute on all countries
wishing to do business along that coast
with this blackmail in mind and claimed
the right of the Koran in order to do so
because when Adams and Jefferson went to
call upon their ambassador and said look
the United States didn't take part in
the Crusades the United States did not
take part in the reconquest of Andalucia
we have no quarrel with the Muslim world
in fact that one of the first treaties
the United States over scientists were
interesting to look it up is an attempt
to make a deal with Tripoli and it's in
that treaty that it is explicitly stated
which is worth knowing and voted on by
Congress I think without a descending
verge the United States says that it is
in no way a Christian country or Society
this attempt at bargaining doesn't work
and furthermore stronger countries
signed separate pieces with the Algiers
and Tripoli and Tunis saying if you will
pay you to leave our ships alone and we
don't mind to say the British if you
attack the Americans because they don't
a longer deserve our protection having
become independent Jefferson says all
right this is going to start we will not
bargain we will not pay we will send the
US Navy and the Marine Corps and we will
bombard these these states until they
give up savory until the group
hostage-taking in piracy it takes only a
couple of years before that works he
doesn't again consult Congress he waits
till the fleet is just far enough over
the horizon to be beyond recall before
he notifies anyone of his action which
has been I think meditated by him by
then for nearly 25 years he's waiting
for a chance for his revenge on these
states
he doesn't insist on a regime change in
these countries but he does insist on a
behavior more
if occation policy change and jaws gated
at the point of a gun it's announced by
him what he really believes that the
United States is an empire of Liberty
and will be an empire for liberty and
will be taken seriously by the other
powers in the world from now on and
we'll back up this with force when and
if it feels it the need perhaps I dwell
on it slightly in my book for another
reason which is that at least that was
one slave trade he was able to put out
because I should now mention my fifth
point which infects and and inflicts all
the others which is the consistent
threat of the slave the slavery argument
in all the phases of his political life
going back to my beginning Jefferson and
his friends in Philadelphia at the
American Academy of Sciences loved to
see new inventions brought and tested
they would have special meetings to do
this
they loved nothing better than to see
someone invent a protest a new balloon
for example Jefferson's very interested
in possibilities of air travel to try
the cutting of a new vine to see if it
would transplant into American soil it's
not entirely Jefferson's for the
Virginia wine isn't quite up to snuff
yet it's better than the Connecticut
chardonnay but it has a way to go to see
a new weapon a new gun being tested and
designed to see a new experiment with
vaccination they'd love to listen they
believe that it would increase the power
of man of a nature and diminish it free
if you like the power of man over men
and they were a little naive in
believing that all technology was
improving and civilizing because of
course mr. Eli Whitney Whitney's mr. Eli
Whitney's cotton gin turned out not to
have this enlightenment effect you've
made in fact the cotton economy stronger
and more profitable and increased the
demand for people who would do the heavy
lifting and work in those fields to feed
the cotton gin and therefore to prolong
chattel slavery long beyond its natural
span if the if such a thing can have a
natural
so from the very beginning it's the worm
in the but it's the some would
melodramatically want to say it's the
original sin of the United States
Jefferson tries to write a paragraph
into the Declaration of Independence
forbidding slavery it's struck out by
the majority because they fear they
can't bring Georgia and the Carolinas
along with them if it's kept in
Jefferson when he doubles the size of
the country at San Samson acre is
besieged by Thomas Paine and many others
don't allow any slaves into the New
Territories don't do that you promised
you wouldn't do it in the Northwest
Territories Joan do it in Louisiana we
have a chance to start again without the
original state he says no we're in a
hurry
we we need to cultivate the sugar there
if we don't do it sugar is almost as bad
as cotton as a slave economy if we don't
do it other countries will rival us in
the Caribbean market we need to move
slaves in there now Payton says again
Jim no don't do it many many thrifty
industrious Protestant German immigrants
who would love the chance to settle and
work in Louisiana territories send them
instead that's a that takes takes too
long and you feel an awful knell of
tolling at this point because with this
vast new access of territory that's
going to clone into more and more new
states very soon almost in Jefferson's
lifetime in fact it it occurs that the
number of slave states becomes to equal
the number of free ones
now the efforts of the American
anti-slavery society have been in vain
and once the number is equal and the
Republic the New Republic is half-slave
and half-free
there's going to be a terrible war and
as Lincoln said later so bleakly and the
war came and so it has to be said of
Thomas Jefferson then he deeded this on
that he knowingly passed this curse on
to the next
it's the next generation and it's it's
not as if because you can find it in the
notes on the state of Virginia it's not
as if he isn't an abolitionist and he
doesn't know what he's doing
if you've read Jefferson on slavery you
don't need to read Frederick Douglass he
understands exactly what's wrong with
slavery he understands why it's
economically inefficient he understands
why it's impossibly unjust and
outrageous he says even if it's true
which he's never sure about even if it's
true that the Africans are different
species in an inferior work even if that
were true it wouldn't justify this and
he also understands the debauching
effect the corrupting and depriving
effect that it has on those who hold
slaves and your profit by them he has
the argument completely down he's forced
to fall back onto the ludicrous
priorities of religious speech in which
he doesn't really believe and to say
that he trembles for his country when he
reflects have got his just whereas of
course if God was just or if there was a
just God there wouldn't be that much to
tremble about he's always showing ago as
well never misses the poor should never
miss a chance to point out the pathetic
fallacies that are involved in religious
invocation so that at every stage when
we even when we we describe him as an
Enlightenment man a man of learning and
science and optimism as a man who
believes in nation-building and in the
expansion of democracy to the West as a
man who believes that there should be a
democratic republic strong enough to
take on all the old empires and vanquish
them and strong enough even to take on
the other Empire the Ottoman Empire and
to force it to give up slavery his steps
a dogged at all times by this fatal
compromise and so one has to accept it
and one has to accept this as the
central one of these many contradictions
I was in California giving a lecture on
Jefferson in San Francisco about a week
ago and happened to be the day that the
Jefferson Elementary School in Berkeley
decided to change its name rather than
have any further association with this
disgusting slaver and changed the name
of the school to Sequoia and I thought
to myself well I could be I could try be
funny about this after all yeah
the trees were here first it's an
arboreal Republic trees have rights too
or I could be annoyed with it thinking
honestly you know what next the
abolition of history the pretense that
we don't come from anywhere but I
decided to think no I didn't really care
what they think there it doesn't matter
what they think it's it's a pseudo
radical position that has no real
consequences it doesn't mean anything
it doesn't commit you to anything it's a
it's a striking of an attitude and there
wouldn't be such a place as Berkeley
Norwood Bishop Berkeley have been able
to imagine the new world being projected
that far west if it wasn't for Thomas
Jefferson so whether they know it or not
they're only entitled to this futile
exercise because of mr. Jefferson's
labors my great mentor of mine the late
I have stone who impelled quite a number
of us into the hope that we could one
day become independent radical
journalists used to call himself when he
was like editing I have Stern's weekly
and I'm sure there's some people here
who still remember that and its
influence in Washington good I've like
more people to nod they're actually but
not more thank you
used to describe yourself as a
Jeffersonian Marxist and this was in the
time of Nixon ISM and he always thought
he'd get into trouble for saying Marxist
but actually he always got into trouble
for saying Jeffersonian because of the
the fatal taint
the fatal compromises of the
Jeffersonian settlement and when taxed
with this used to say well nonetheless
one has to recognize that history is a
tragedy and not a morality tale and
that's how I end my book and that's our
end this phase ladies and gentlemen
thank you for patience I'm I'm all yours
thank you
I don't know if it would be invidious if
I point it to questioners you are not to
know for example whether or not I seeded
the room with members of my immediate
family will you trust me to point to
people very well bring it on then sir
you mentioned that there are two
biographical essays that help you
understand the origins of America
Jefferson and Abraham Lincoln
are you planning to write anything about
Lincoln no I'm not my water right next
about Thomas Paine but I think the only
two presidencies I've some people might
want to add Theodore excuse me Franklin
Roosevelt to this the presence is that
in a sense create the world we actually
live in the jefferson one is in a way
the most much and that's difficult
because his political life is so long i
mean by the time he goes to administer
to paris in 1788 which is very senior
job in the US government from from then
on he's in power almost continuously
with nearly a quarter of a century as
Minister secretary state vice-president
and twice president and that's before he
founds the University of Virginia and
does the Jefferson Bible and after doing
the Declaration of Independence and the
Virginia statute on religious freedom
the last three being the only things
that he had on his headstone as you
probably know what his headstone where
there's no mention of any divinity as
there was no matter for cloth at his
bedside waning tonight he asked to be
remembered as the founder of the
University of Virginia the author of the
Declaration independence and of the
Virginia statute on religious freedom
didn't think the two presidencies or
Secretary of State worth mentioning it
sir it is a remarkable thing perhaps I
should have said something about the
Jefferson Bible I will in a second I
wanted to say just one thing about
Lincoln that accidental and in a way
completely meaningless discovery that I
made
while doing this I just hadn't realized
that Abraham Lincoln and Charles Darwin
were born on exactly the same day I
regard Darwin is much the greater of the
two emancipator's I must say but the
great tragedy of Jefferson in all his
investigations into the ecology and
archeology and nature and back and what
should we call him substratum of the
state of Virginia is that he's still
living even though he's a man of the
Enlightenment and a man of science in
the era of alchemy and phlogiston effect
he and the French biologist Buffon have
an argument about why are these sea
shells so high up on the mountains how
do you think get there I have no idea
they don't know enough to it's maddening
to think what he might have been able to
do if he could see as far as any of us
can that's really the tragedy of him
he's also in the era when race theory is
still possible he speculates he thinks
well why are these why are these black
chaps from Africa and Chapare says so
biddable is it because they're inferior
biologically is it something to do with
the climate they come from still he's
still at that stage he can't make up his
mind he sort of hopes not but he
suspects it's true it's very sad
you
yeah do you think Jeffersonian democracy
is a chance in Iraq or do you think the
critics earn there's just a certain - II
criticizing effort um conceptually the
flag of Kurdistan in my lapel gentleman
asked if the Iraqi flag the force of
your question is just as good I mean
camp can to be Jeffersonian democracy in
other countries well I used to get
taunted about this a few months ago you
would say so your your Rakhi pals are
going to be Jeffersonian Democrats are
they and I said well none of my Nawrocki
Oh Kurdish friends owned any slaves so I
should think probably not but I realized
that was a cheap report I made it all
the same but I was boring actually from
the factory of their for cabaret to sort
of give them the cheese well I think
what can say is the following the
Russian Revolution is finished to
stretch it over the Chinese Revolution
of 94 day 49 likewise it servi survived
by mutating metamorphosing into
something else
human Revolution is dead in the water
has been for some time
the American Revolution is the last one
standing and its principles if for
anything that can provide what you might
call universal emulation or somewhat
crude appeared export I wouldn't say
that the principles of 1789 were dead by
any means but the Universal Declaration
of late wild alarm the rights of man in
France was probably written by Jefferson
and by Thomas Paine so it takes a part
in the American Revolution to I've been
to all three of the axis of evil'
countries in the last few years I think
I'm the only writer and I'm a writer who
has done that and just some other very
[ __ ] up places to and in none of them
would it not be a huge improvement to
have a written constitution with the
Bill of Rights and above all the
separation of church and Party from
stage so yes there are many people who
do hope and do wish to adopt what might
be called a Jeffersonian
see and it's just a really question of
whether we care about them or support
them or not but even if we don't they
will still be there from Ray
given the popularity of the eugenics
movement and eugenics way of thinking
social Darwinism that was popular among
certain circles in this country in
certain classes well beyond world war ii
yes was some of the assumptions
associated with that how can we now in
the 60s or now be judgmental of an
eighteenth-century man which has studied
empires in history where slavery was as
natural as breathing air notions of
eugenics as somehow being creation of a
superior person and along a little path
if you will was a popular and openly
discussed was the question
audible tool yes um let me just see if I
can venture Lacroix's you the gentleman
says that given the the appalling
influence of eugenic theories in our own
time up to our own time as you I think
you put it
how can one be judgmental as he phrases
it about the the attitude to slavery of
the 18th century where I think you said
it was as natural as breathing if not
just in the United States you mean it
not just in America but in Africa and
Asia and Lee and elsewhere was that a
fair price of your question well you
hear this kind of point made sometimes
also about the anti-semitism of say
cheers' Elliot people said well in those
days my old anti-semitism was the norm
was common and so forth so let's not use
our standards to judge Australia I don't
think that's true for example there were
people who his contemporaries Jogger
Jordan was one George Orwell was another
wouldn't put up with it and didn't think
it should be accepted as a as a common
social prejudice so yes one has to
extend the right to be judgmental and
yet there's no question that
just to think the three names I mean
Benjamin Franklin Thomas Paine and and
Benjamin Rush were all in the both by
1775 before before there was the United
States for the members of the American
anti-slavery society and I think there
was a Mennonite petition against slavery
in Pennsylvania or even earlier than
that even though it was true that up
till then as far as I know there's no
Christian protest against slavery until
the 17th century Christianity is not as
compatible with slavery recommends it in
many places in the Bible mandates is in
fact in some places doesn't condemn it
in the 10 commandments certainly all is
it - and genocide
to be carried out in other as just
Judaism for the same reason and as jazz
Islam mandates slavery or license said
and certainly did in Africa and in the
and in the Mediterranean and as far
north as Ireland in fact some the does
the famous song called Rule Britannia
that some of you may know with the
refrain of which is Britons never never
never shall be slaves and it's written
by Michael James Thompson in about 1750
and the reason why it is in there is
because certainly British and Irish
people are being taken as slaves by
Muslim pirates and their and their rogue
states but this was a huge campaign you
know the tiniest villages in England
would raise money for to try and redeem
the captives and this happened also in
America before Jefferson sent the fleet
they kept hearing terrible stories about
what happened to American slaves in
Tunis but for that very reason the more
the more that that tone was struck that
slavery was intolerable than no one
would should ever be one it did become a
little easier to raise the subject of
whether we should be inflicting it as
well as suffering from it there was a
dialectical relationship between the two
things and so yes I think that people
are the same moral animal at all he
parks it isn't it isn't a matter of the
superiority of our own time that allows
asked to be judgmental because in what
possible respect could we say that our
own vantage point was a superior one sir
the general wants to know why he should
buy this one and not another well it's
the only one that's written by me and I
did not want to be the only person in
the United States who had not written
about Fiat honest answer it gives one a
certain position in society to have done
this and there are so many good ones
that it's quite easy to do a short one I
think that'll have to be my defense and
also well when I was asked to do it I
would never have had the nerve to
propose myself as his biographer
when I was invited to do it I thought I
had to say yes because we are anyone who
writes about America which is the great
subject he's in fact always writing
about Jefferson in one way or another
it's latent its imbricated in the whole
argument about about the country so it's
part of one's education I suppose I
might make the claim that into my book
materializes that so when you think
about Jefferson think about the United
States and vice versa so I bought mine
here and also an I haven't read it yet
but I'm looking forward to reading it
thank you for writing a concise
biography
of Jefferson I also plan on presenting
it to my daughter will be attending the
University of Virginia in the fall so
I'm hoping that she will read so thank
you again question I had how does your
book treat Jefferson's relationship if
at all with Adams I remember reading
about the relationship in the McCullough
biography of Adams and it seems like a
fascinating relationship I don't know if
it's treated in your book or if you came
across it in you are preparation for
writing for Jefferson and Adams is is
inescapable it's very interesting
actually they start off I really dislike
another and really not being in any way
similar and Adams is a bluff ol Tory in
some ways and Jefferson suspects him of
being a pawn of the British indeed Adams
did propose the ludicrous styling for
President Washington it's in the book I
can't quote it exactly but it's
something like his presidential
magnificence and Supreme Commander it's
like an El Salvadoran title for General
Washington and Jefferson Lampoon and
ridicule distance of mr. president will
define thanks but he thought Adams was a
secret angler main as he put it and this
also of course licensed Jefferson in
taking the view that he did that it was
perfectly alright to be privately
aligned with the French Revolution and
they cordially detest one another
because of this I mean if I think the
difference if I could find a an
encapsulation for it would be this if
Adams used the word democratic or
democratical he would mean it as an
insult as most people then did what we
might now say some say autocratic mob
rule is what would be meant by that it's
as far as I'm aware until Thomas Paine
rights the rights of man the word
democratical remarks is never used in a
positive sense Jefferson was a great
admirer of the rights of men and in fact
contributed an introduction to its
American edition very much angering
Adams by doing so so that and the
argument over France divides them
terribly
an atom's doesn't at all like being
defeated by Jefferson and doesn't stay
there's inauguration leaves town
sourpuss the correspondence goes on
later into life and it becomes rather
charming as they get older and as they
become the only two real survivors of
the early attacks a lot of
Correspondence about wine have you tried
this new case of saturated our Virginia
wines getting any better all this a lot
of a lot of talk about wine and it's
strange enough it's Adams two encourages
Jefferson to do his his Bible miss
Jefferson Bible genitive how many of you
know about this but in retirement he
took a copy of the New Testament in one
hand and a pair of scissors in the other
and cut out everything from the New
Testament that was absurd or evil or
wicked or stupid or mythical or
contradictory or otherwise Oh Cheers
she left him with a very short book as
you can easily imagine which you can now
get the beautiful addition from the
Unitarian Church in which Jefferson had
a slight interest he had penis sort of
the window reformed Jews in those days
so he thought unitarianism was the next
best thing that's my surmise and who
Adams is the one who encourages him to
do it strange that I don't quite know
whether it was Adams thinking I'm not
going to so you do to it but that is in
fact the origin of the Jefferson
whatever which is well worth reading sir
you spoke about the war against the
Barbary Coast
pirates almost as a kind of
idealistic campaign
I'm just wondering whether where they're
also prevailing economic reasons behind
that particular adventure in other words
protecting shipping
now if the gentleman asks whether the
war against the Barbary States was
merely a matter of principle or was a
matter of economics I mean it was first
and foremost a matter of economics the
freedom of navigation across the
Atlantic and into the Mediterranean was
being compromised by this I mean
American ships were being captured not
just off the coast of North Africa but
by North African Raiders deep into the
Atlantic and way up into the North Sea
of the English Channel so and most
European countries would make a separate
piece on this and do their own bargain
or trade with pay their own ransom or
strike their own deal with these to
avoid molestation
so Jefferson's view was he tried for he
tried for what he called a concert of
powers to get an agreement with Britain
and France and Spain and Portugal and
Malta rather just say we'll collectively
put it down and no one would do it they
will feel thought they could get their
own advantage all right then well we'll
enforce the freedom of the seas for
everybody and will bombard their ports
and sink their fleet they also let him
actually very interesting compromise
with all diplomatic initiative he made a
friend of John Paul Jones isn't long
before he was president when he was
first when he was Minister in Paris and
having to pay for John Paul Jones his
mistress by the way at all points in
Jefferson's life I might just mention
this now I guess no one's to ask me
about it at all points you realize what
a sexual being he was and how close was
his commander the facts of life it's
always there he's always handling
delicate matters such as John Paul Jones
as mistress when he's a minister and the
and providing women of the night to the
Islamic end voice when they come to
Washington and expect to be amused he
and Madison raised a private budget to
keep them entertained and I can give you
some other examples of it I mentioned it
because so many historians write about
Jefferson as if he didn't have a dick
which he's sure dared well he makes a
friend of John Paul Jones you realize
this is one of those men who's meant to
be an admiral
been meant to be a Navy guy he's out
currently beached and broke and screwing
around appearances why don't you go and
work for the Empress Catherin of Russia
who needs a decent naval commander in
the Black Sea because there you can you
can make life hard for the Turks who are
the Imperial commanders of the Ottoman
States of North Africa why don't you do
that keep you busy keep you in practice
when we build our own Navy and we'll
inflict pain on the Ottoman Muslim
empire in the meanwhile Jones goes and
does this and you had usually thought a
long time ahead about things of this
kind and about making alliances in
tactical maneuvers and he was never one
to forget any kind of grievance or
offense or crotch I like that in a guy
or a president anyway yes nothing to do
mr. Jefferson has to do with an imminent
urgent time I heard once that you would
spend some time with war case yes if so
I wonder how you two got along well it's
a change of pace the gentleman wants to
know is it true that I once spent some
time with folk a Lewis book as in Buenos
Aires which I did in the summer in the
winter of them there was summer in
Argentina of 1977 at the height of the
what we history now calls the dirty war
between the Argentine military regime
and its civilian opponents and the man
who I consider to be the greatest writer
produced by South America and the
greatest appreciator in the
spanish-speaking world of English
literature the greatest critic of it was
by then more or less blind he couldn't
move out of his apartment which made all
this works of his about the infinite
library and the role of memory in the
unconscious rather than sight seemed
even more affecting and we talked for a
while he asked me if I'd read to him
because he had new visitors and he
couldn't
he could point to where everything was
on his shelf even in this infinite
library and asked me to read Kipling
which I did in particular the harp do
you know the harp song of the day and
women well I know how it starts it's a
it's the morn it's the morning of the
wives and daughters of the Vikings that
their men prefer war to them and prefer
the sea and fighting and violence and
danger to them and it's what is a woman
that you forsake her and the half fire
the homemaker to go with that old grey
Widowmaker it's a wonderful poem and all
of the words in it are essentially
anglo-saxon crippling picked only
ancient English words to write it so at
that time Borg is was very Pro
dictatorship in Argentina he said he he
had hated Juan Peron very much and quite
rightly I think as a demagogue and a
crowd pleaser a populist and thought
that the military were more classy and
said it's better to have a government of
gentlemen that of pimps actually it was
a much ruler worth as an Argentine work
called can fin Flair oh it's a dockland
term which is much ruder than I could I
will not translate for you and when I
told him I couldn't come back the next
day so I had to go to Chile so but if
you see that nice General Pinochet do
please give him my greetings he's a he's
a true gentleman and once gave me a
literary prize but he towards it of his
life he he changed his mind on all that
and described the the mad war over the
Falklands as some two bald men fighting
over at home
and began to criticize the Argentine
regime for the desaparecidos that
disappeared in the torture that's awful
so he died as a man of honor but that
secondary I mean we won can't one can't
sir
what calm politicized the Magnificent
literary work he did in the first man in
the hemisphere to appreciate Joyce for
example I'm not he had you read town to
and he virtually wouldn't let him out of
his house for five or six days where he
was there pressing her to keep wonders
he's one reading and very anti-catholic
Chesterton's chest marvelous Roger
such a pity became a Catholic became a
Catholic my god so do I see another hand
yes mistaken you have correct me if I'm
wrong but you have some background
the new left movement and I was
wondering if you had a very different
view of Jefferson back in the day and if
so how your view has evolved and changed
and what factors have caused you to
reconsider I'm asked if it's true that I
have a new left background and if so
whether evolving away from that has
changed my attitude to Thomas Jefferson
that'd be the forceful question well
actually I'm young enough to have been
old left as well as old enough to have
been new left with an early left review
I had a lot of friends have sometimes
written for ideas but some of the
definitions of you left I wouldn't
wouldn't cover me in the SDS and so
forth wouldn't but yes I I still think
like a Marxist and I was one or am one
sunny was one in a socialist sense for
most of my life and the attitude to the
American Revolution was actually the one
thing I wish the left never made up its
mind strange you know I think because
they thought it had been superseded by
more modern ways wasn't true of Marx as
a matter of fact or angles I mean Marx
and Engels wrote that repeatedly that
the great country of backwardness and
superstition and tyranny and ignorance
and barbarism was Russia and the great
country of the future and of equality
and Liberty was the United States and
they were particularly strongly their
defense of Abraham Lincoln organizing
movements in support of the Union in
Europe Henry Adams in his memoir says
Marxist they're almost their only friend
in London at the time advising Lincoln
he wrote several pieces about it for
Horace Greeley's New York Tribune
advising Lincoln to fire general
McClellan pro-slavery stressing the
importance of ironclad ships over
sale the superiority of capitalist move
of feudalism and slavery and the rest to
it very very interesting with it
there is another strain in and very much
not what they teach you in school I have
the feeling that probably it's not
taught in American high schools that
Karl Marx was Lincoln's best friend
would I be right in this so nice yes and
I think so and the Lincoln thought so
too but there is another strain in the
left which I mean eventuates in this
nonsense in the Jefferson Elementary
School in Berkeley the other day and
also with the writing of professor Noam
Chomsky who is a very important figure
on the American Left so he calls himself
an anarchist he keeps forgetting he is
one just the moments it might do him
some good but he is a venerated major
influence on the making left and I
realized a few years ago that there was
a difference between him trust Chomsky
mean and my Selfridge he did not finally
think that the United States of America
was a good idea
he thought it had been all genocide
since Columbus basically I mean that's
not simplifying his opinion by very much
and as I said about the Berkeley motion
to change the name of the School of
Sequoia in a way it doesn't make any
difference it's it's a radical attitude
it's not a radical position because it
doesn't commit you to anything doesn't
mean anything it doesn't represent
anything actually there are times when
it can have significance if you
basically think United States is a bad
idea then you may feel a sneaking
sympathy for others who feel the same
such as for example theocratic nihilists
who believe it's a crusader Jewish
racket and of course it's very important
that people make up their minds about
this now and stop fooling around about
it
wouldn't you say so so - summer would
you say them that your view of Jefferson
has been consistent over time that you
you had no point to ever subscribe to
that when you call Berkeley
interpretation no I would know I never
there never was a period in my life when
I thought that I was wanted to come to
United States I had a very strong
ambition to come here and identification
with it well I guess I haven't quite
answered the second half of your
question which is this what difference
would I has it made citing him more I
tell you what about the slavery so which
everyone thinks they know about and
everyone does know about so it's a great
deal worse than I'd of a suspect because
it's not just his failure to abolish it
it's his fetch of commitment to extend
it and prolong it and deepen and
entrench it that's inescapable if you if
you decide that you're not going to get
rid of a thing like that you are not in
fact taking a neutral position
you're not saying well we can't do it
now we'll do it some other time you are
you're making the other decision you're
saying no we're going to continue with
it at all there's implications
opportunity including a civil war in
which the whole Republic might be
destroyed so it's very very difficult to
overstate how ghastly that is something
I certainly had not understood that
element of it but the Enlightenment
ideas persist in their own right it
seems to me and are the negation of some
of these practices so there's that much
to play for
yeah can you give it some way what would
he think of it well I've given up on
this writing about George Orwell
persuading me not to do this if you
don't mind because people would keep on
saying well what would all we'll say
about this or that and I think you can
you can do it up to a certain point or
we'll die unfortunately when he was 46
and I think I think I was strong enough
to claim that I knew and could prove
that he would not have supported the war
in Vietnam which Norman Podhoretz and
other neoconservative said they thought
he would because he could have been
alive for it and he had enough knowledge
of and dislike for European colonialism
in Asia very intense dislike and he
would have known enough to know already
in fact in his late writings from Paris
and the 40s did know enough to know that
French colonialism was being restored in
Indochina after the war and everyone
knows if they don't know they should
know that the American war in Vietnam is
a mere extension an attempt to to
prolong the life of French colonial
Indochina so I think I could reasonably
make a case that I did know would say
what he would said about that I couldn't
have said what he would have said about
some the Iraq war for example there
would only be guesswork however there
was a symposium on biography recently of
the Smithsonian which I was asked here
with greatest superior firepower
Michael quarter for example whose book
killed Ulysses Grant is in the same
series and Francine prose I believe and
some others and Michael Cordes said look
at one thing about girl must never do is
say at this point he must have thought
or that moment he must have realized so
he must have felt he mustn't ever do it
it undermines their integrity as an
author it goes farther than you can
possibly know give it up and I thought
well I've heard that before and I've
always agree with them I've always
nodded at the right place it's a
completely respectable opinion
but I had to say that I am certain that
I know what Jefferson thought when he
first saw Sally Hemings arrived in Paris
I don't know anything about anything if
I don't know what he thought and what he
thought was maybe for the only time his
life oh man there is a god that's what
he thought
Wow was what he thought I think one has
to do it sometimes if you could see the
United States today I think the thing
that were most amazed him would actually
be the position of women it's very
interesting how little he pays attention
to that he takes for granted the the
place the domestic place of women the
American womanhood would amaze him now
and stir him I think a bit but it would
absolutely astound
I need some more water if someone can
get me that or something liquid
yeah
well thousand how many was someone about
whom Jefferson is consistently unfair
and though I think well think like and
believe that you couldn't have had the
United States without Jefferson it's
probably fair to say that you couldn't
have had it without Jefferson plus
Hamilton because Jefferson really does
believe in a way in the agrarian future
the rural and bucolic society and the
small community partly owning chattel
slaves and partly small enough to
conduct business
intimately whereas Hamilton correctly
sees that the future the United States
is mercantile and free trade and
business and urbanization and
Jefferson's one Bank and Jefferson is
one of those people I think you've
probably deep down thought that paper
money was immoral somehow unsound
if you can't bite it it's not cash and
took a very reactionary attitude on all
this but as every as with everything
else would compromise if he thought it
would advance the general cause and he
said to Hamilton effectively well you
can have your economic policy if we can
have the capital in Virginia which is
why we're stuck here today
and Hamilton was very critical of the
Louisiana Purchase but as was Adams but
I think probably because they were
furious that they hadn't been able to do
it themselves to be fair to them
rancheros book on Hamilton I thought was
excellent and I say it was full of very
very useful information and you have to
send Jefferson was a very cold person
as I've said before very ruthless almost
Leninist in his ruthlessness and I think
he was almost publicly pleased when
Aaron Berger killed Halton he really
hated him and suspected Hamilton of
being partly Black Caribbean upstart
immigrant which by the way Hamilton may
have been we don't know but Justin
really thought of him as the total
inferior and was as mean about him as he
could be and you see a lot of the newer
side of Jefferson's character from
studying its relations with help
The Jeffersons ideas
was we just pure Jeffersonian
now I think Johnson in alliance with
other men of the Enlightenment in his
own country our country and others was a
important revolutionary that he
definitely believed this was for export
that he thought that it should spread or
be spread and the one day the United
States would be a superpower for
democracy strong enough to take on
anyone else and I'd live the old empires
and very few of the others had a vision
as intense as that so I think that may
be one reason why it's justifiable for
us to say to use the word Jeffersonian a
democracy in the same sentence as we as
we in a shorthand way still do you know
how do you reconcile Jefferson's javea
support for the American Revolution
where you know you see and the
Federalists Madison writing that man is
imperfect and therefore you need the
Constitution to check him with his
support of the French Revolution which
was very small D Democratic did sort of
believe in the perfectibility of man and
the ability of any check on man was just
going to be a bad man well Jefferson was
lucky in the sense to skip the arguments
of Philadelphia I mean one of the he's a
lucky guy drafts in many ways he's often
absent just when it's convenient most
convenient for him to be he doesn't have
to take a position about the Federalist
Papers people send him their copies or
their comments on it he comments him
privately in Paris about it and he's in
keys note and obviously is in two minds
about it a lot of the time in the same
way by the way he's in opposition very
briefly when Adams decides to build a
navy and a Marine Corps to fight France
and he lets Madison Jefferson let's
Madison criticizes in in the Congress
while he's staying Perman
Charlottesville's not saying anything
what he thinks is valence bills this
fleet I'm going to send it to North
Africa
he's you know he's Schrute Fox like I
don't think he was a total believer in
the perfectibility of man and his his
influence in France was with and upon
men like the Marquis de Lafayette who
are not jack about but but it has to be
said though that when the Jacobite turn
on Lafayette and even on pain and try to
institute a sort of engineering of the
human personality through terror
Jefferson thinks that may not be too
high price to pay for the swipe of
French Revolution he's pretty he's very
Rufus about in fact his writings on it
are exactly like the writings of an
early communist would be about the need
to defend the USSR from all all enemies
it must be it must be defended at all
costs now
well I twice in my book quote Henry
Adams because it's the most convenient
summary of how much the United States is
different at the end of the Jefferson
presidency how much more of a modern
country it's become how much more
navigable how much more densely
populated how much more committed to
sending settlers out and then
recognizing the new states they create
how much more prosperous and how much
more military power for me the best
encapsulating paragraphs of that are in
Adams so I merely annexed them for my
purposes that that's what gives you an
idea of the scope especially of his
first presidency so marvelous all of
Henry Ellis history and of course his
men was a wonderfully interesting and no
longer talked in school
come back
the most way to read there was one lady
the back which she may have given out
there she hasn't be up
it's lost in the labyrinth of Homeland
Security thank you
I'd like
and diverse ways
well I don't know how well-stocked this
bookstore is but they might sell you a
copy of love publishing war which is a
collection of essays that I brought out
this year and in there there's quite a
long piece about the collapse of history
teaching of the accident and I could I
can probably go through through through
the curriculum in that way as long as it
didn't have to do anything about science
teaching but I mean I teach a course on
it's basically on the English literary
canon and in the new school in New York
every year and it's a graduate course
and every year becomes more more
difficult to find a book that everyone
is read it was to have a common stock of
references or a common bookshelf with
which one can begin a discussion and
that the level which one can find a
common a commonality is sinking every
time one you three old accounts say on
Fitzgerald and to some extent when you
can't be sure about that now it could be
the Simpsons and Toni Morrison the
second which bitter which is not
progress this Simpson said better than
anything that was around when I was a
kid I mean what if that's what one is
counting on for irony and one is in low
water
so I yeah believe me it's in my mind
we've have it you just wish it was
longer well that's fine I can I think we
can close on that thank you very much
for coming